مجرد التفكير انك تحت الانقاض فهو تفكير
مرعب ومخيف فما بالكم بالعديد من
المواطنين الذين ما زالوا عالقين تحت
الانقاض فرق الانقاذ ما زالت تواصل
اعمالها حتى هذه اللحظه لليوم الخامس على
التوالي يقومون بانتشال الجثث وايضا هناك
ناجين يقومون بانقاذهم ومساعدتهم واخراجهم
من بين الانقاب هذه المدينه هي مدينه
كهرمان مرعش مركز الزلزال في البلاد مدينه
منكوبه الحديث عن اكثر من 940 مبنى هدم
بالكامل دمر بالكامل هناك المئات من
الاليات والالاف من عمال الانقاذ مازالوا
يواصلون اعمالهم حتى هذه اللحظه لكن
المخاوف الان تتزايد وتتعاظم كثيرا مع
نفاد الوقت فالفرص تتضاءل امام وجود تحت
الانقاض غسان ابو الاوز العربيه
كهرمان مرعش